at a small fishing village just south of
Santiago Chile
Jose Barrios and other fishermen are
getting ready to head out to sea
things here appear calm but a state of
emergency remains in effect in the
country and it's a subject that's on
everyone's mind what's happening in the
country isn't about politics this is a
social problem
Chile's president has announced reforms
to social programs in an effort to calm
the crisis but Jose says people have
lost confidence in political leaders the
president of the Republic has only
patched a wound but there is still a
wound underneath until that wound is
treated and heals the problems of our
country are not going away
China is Latin America's most developed
nation but over the past week protests
have highlighted a growing angst among
the citizenry the unrest began over an
increase of 30 pesos - the cost of metro
transport which amounts to about 10
cents of a dollar that cost increase was
like a spark to a powder keg in a
country where many were already
complaining about a worsening wealth gap
between the rich and the middle class
Chile economists like Patricio Navya say
a solution out of the crisis will
require a delicate compromise from the
country's political elite and the
perception is that Chile is not in a
crisis she is in a difficult situation
but we are developed enough for everyone
to have better living conditions so it's
a matter of distribution if we can
better distribute the wealth and the
opportunities that exist in Chile
everyone is going to be better off
after a week of unrest demonstrations in
China have spread to other parts of the
country a recent national poll found
that 83% of Chileans are in favor of the
ongoing social mobilizations even in
Sheila's smallest communities far away
from the protests that have paralyzed
the country's capital the discontent
from citizens is palpable for everyday
Chileans the crisis isn't about an
increase of 30 pesos to the cost of
public transportation it's about 30
years of policies that many see as being
bad for the nation fishermen like Jose
Barrios say they hope political leaders
will act on the demands of demonstrators
before their quiet seaside town joins in
the protests now Miriam you've seen we
saw those images of people starting to
gather throughout the course of today
Friday here in the Chilean capital we
can confirm that there's somewhere
around half a million people that have
gathered in blasted athaliah this is an
iconic part of the city where political
movements have traditionally started and
gathered throughout the course of this
country's history there was an
expectation that Friday being the
beginning of the weekend here in Chile
would be a busy day an eventful day for
protests but I don't think anybody could
have imagined the turnout and we should
note there are still more people that
are joining in the demonstrations that's
that are taking place today protests
that are remained mostly peaceful until
now we should keep in mind that over the
past week one of the biggest points of
anger from demonstrators has been the
heavy-handed response from government
authorities from the military from armed
forces who have been captured on film
using excessive force it's captured the
attention of international observers
from the United Nations who have said
that this amounts to violations of human
rights in fact the UN is sending in a
delegation on Monday that will be here
for four weeks conducting investigations
into these alleged human rights
violations Miriam thank you very much
with the latest on those protests
unfolding in Santiago Chile mani Rapallo